welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Spider-Man across the spider
versus filmmakers say they created 280
spider people for this movie half of
them are really background ones
distinguished mostly by color and other
unique characteristics but with the help
of our writers Jordan Eric I went
through this movie several times to
identify at least 100 Fighter people in
across the spider verse that was our
goal and I love to do this because these
cameos are freaking Bonkers hey new
rockstars will be at RTX in Austin July
7th through 9th join us for an exclusive
meet and greet new rockstars live and
more go to rtxaustin.com and get your
badge today and please subscribe to all
three channels on our Network and
support us with some merch at
nerdright.shop and this video was made
in partnership with the Lord of the
Rings Gollum available for sale right
now on Xbox PlayStation and PC more on
them later alright here we go 100 spider
people one Miles Morales from Earth 1610
you know him Gwen Stacy from Earth 65 3
Peter B Parker from 1610b pravicher
prabhakar from 50101 Miguel O'Hara from
923 miles G Morales from Earth 42. I'm
counting him because I still think he
has a future as a Spider-Man Jessica
Drew from 404 Hobie Brown from 138 of
course our friend Spider-Man Noir from
the first film and Penny Parker and
spider ham all three of whom make campus
in this movie number 12 Margot spider
bite from Earth 22191 Ben Riley the
Scarlet spot voiced by Andy Sandberg in
this movie then Spider-Man 1967 voiced
by yorma tacon who's a 2d Spider-Man
then the Lego Spider-Man he was animated
by a 14 year old Preston motanaga we
meet Peter parked Carr from 53931 the
Insomniac Spiderman that's from Earth
1048 The Spectacular Spider-Man Josh
Keaton coming back here Spider-Man
Unlimited shows up in this movie and I'm
counting these guys number 20 to Maguire
Peter Parker because he shows up in the
web of life and Destiny Andrew Garfield
Peter Parker who also shows up in the
way of life and Destiny and Tom Holland
Peter Parker from The MCU because he is
referenced he's off screen though
there's the web Slinger Patrick O'Hara
from Earth 31 913. there's a popsicle
Spider-Man who makes a little blob of a
cameo there's Malala Windsor from
earth835 she asks is anyone supposed to
spot there's spider's side who's
mentioned from Earth 616 which is
interesting there's a Last Stand
Spider-Man from Earth 312-500 there's
the tarantula of Earth 1610 a there's
spider cat who claws at Miles face
there's spider Rex AKA picture to Parker
there's Charlotte Weber the sun spider
who makes it Cameo make it a great
crutch pun there's the spider wolf then
there's Metro boomin's version of
Spider-Man who makes the Cameo tiny
miles there's nowhere else to run
there's the cyborg Spider Woman that's
the biggest clunkiest spider person who
you see in the mob there's a Canadian
Spider Woman AKA spider Canada who's
often carrying a hockey stick there's
the Flash Thompson Spider-Man aka
Captain spider is often wearing his
letterman jacket there's chibi
Spider-Man the little fella who's always
hopping around there's Mabel Riley from
Earth 803 that's a steampunk lady spider
she's got the mechanical Waldo's there's
Mayday Parker from 616b there's a manga
verse Spider-man who's got the
interesting gloves there's a bombastic
Batman who has a brown paper's head
there's a spider armor mark one spider
armor Mark two and spider armor Mark III
there's a traffic cop Spider-Man there's
Ezekiel Sims aka the therapist
Spider-Man then there's Max Bourne who's
a friend of Miguel O'Hara maxboard is
Spider-Man 2211 from 9500 there's Mary
Jane Parker AKA spinnerette from a 2015
limited run renew your valve storyline
and her daughter Anna May Parker
spiderling there's a spider monkey who
of course shows up there's Future
Foundation Spider-Man then there's
doppelganger also spider knight from
Ultimate Spider-Man there's the prince
of Arachne from 71004 there's Jessica
Drew spider woman's classic suit there's
Julia Carpenter Spider Woman there's a
samurai Spider-Man there's a quippy
spider person Elizabeth Perkins there's
superior Spider-Man that's a Doc Ock
that's in control of Peter's body
there's the stealth big time Spider-Man
suit there's a velocity suit from the
Spider-Man games there's a very very
thick Bruce Banner Spider-Man he's part
of the control unit in mumbatin with a
Canon event starts to fall apart he's
like the most muscular Spider-Man in
this because he's a Hulk now if you want
to get a good sense of Middle Earth you
need a local to show you around who
better than Gollum who knows everything
about the most dangerous places in the
realm and learn it the hard way the Lord
of the Rings Gollum is a new epic action
adventure game set Middle Earth where
you play his Golem on his quest to
retrieve his precious the game takes
place in parallel to the events of
Fellowship of the Ring adding new layers
to the story you know and love while
Legolas Gimli and Frodo were hogging all
the glory Gollum was being hunted down
not just by Naz Ghouls and Sauron but
also by Gandalf and frienduel dealing
with Orcs elves in all manner of creepy
crawlies climb the mountains of Mordor
sneak around merkwood and outwit the
most powerful characters of Middle Earth
We're super excited for this game and
you should be too click the link in this
video's description to watch the trailer
and purchase the game on ps4 PS5 Xbox
One Xbox series XS or PC and thanks
again to Lord of the Rings Gollum for
sponsoring this video there's an iron
spider one who's the red with the the
yellow pattern over it there's Peter
Parker from neversoft's 2000 spider game
there's a shocker Spider-Man this is
Spider-Man who just kind of looks like
the Shocker with the shoulder pads
there's Kane Parker's Scarlet Spider now
there is Spider-Man 1978 to Yuka
Yamashiro he did not came here in this
movie I assume he's gonna come in the
next one but Phil Lord says the
character is designed so I'm counting
him there's an Underoos of Spider-Man
there's a dormammu versus Spider-Man
there's She-Hulk Spider Woman woman then
the sixth one I think might be my
favorite honestly this is Anya Corazon
the aranya she's got an amazing suit
that just kind of assembles over her
with huge gauntlets she's got short hair
she works out and she's got an
interesting Carabiner which raise your
hand if you know what that means I'm not
gonna tell you you gotta look it up
there's the fear itself Spider-Man who's
in the top left corner cool fact his
suit is made from Asgardian Tech my
friends now there's this tall beefy
Spiderman in a black and dark red suit
there's a woman with classic red and
blue spider suit who's holding a coffee
cup there's what I'm pretty sure is a
Deadpool Spider-Man there's this one
that I'm calling a newspaper strip
Spidey it just looks different than the
negative Spidey so I think he's a
different one there was a Spider-Man
newspaper strip that was mostly in black
and white now then there's another one
with a big floppy sun hat kind of
reminds me of Kung Lao from Mortal
Kombat there's a Spiderman with a laptop
who's also kind of a monochrome then the
spider that's Peter Parker from Earth
15. then there's the Insomniac Miles
Morales who's walking with the Insomniac
Peter in that shot there's what I'm
calling the Purple Rain Spiderman that's
a Prowler inspired suit from the
Insomniac Games his logo is a different
color but I think it's kind of connected
to it there's a new Fantastic Four suit
Spider-Man there's a gray and white
suited Spider-Man with an interesting
facial patterns on the mask there's one
I'm calling leg day Spider-Man lifting
the huge block in the workout gym who
gets crushed when his legs gets whipped
out there's one I'm calling Suns out
guns out Spider-Man who looks like he's
just going Sleepless there's a thick
blue Spider-Man with a red bib pattern
on his chest there's one I'm calling the
Silver Surfer Spider-Man coasting on the
mob on the train there's a black and
white looking like a telenovela
Spider-Man like you might be wearing a
sombrero there's at least two to three
more in this mob that I'm pretty sure or
not anywhere else I'm counting them as
well and we'll end with these last two
bringing up the rear because they're
slow a purple and teal Duo and I love
these two side by side because it remind
me of the early 90s drink cup that I'd
always get and always just takes me back
okay that's it I think in there I got
100 or at least I got very close hey
remember to subscribe to all three of
our channels the Deep dive the break
room and the main new rock stars channel
coverage of all the stuff you love you
can support us by grabbing some merch at
nerdrive.shop follow me
and we'll see you next time everybody
bye
foreign
[Music]